all right yo what's going on reject
nation it's Greg outlet here is Wendy
Lee here when do we who was I don't know
I'm doing she's learned this Collider
videos and more importantly she has her
own YouTube channel where she does
reactions and reviews she is fantastic
on there does it with her husband Texas
is his name and it's the movie couple
channel I'm telling you guys she is
fantastic
she doesn't need the whole Collider crew
to be there just go watch the movie
couple channel she just needs her one
partner in crime and they are great
together Texas you think yeah Texas
texted Wendy in Texas speaking of Texas
Ygritte goes west wow what the Texas
before located we're watching the red
man Taylor
red band trailer number two oh
restricted mode okay so I saw the first
tray to the Ford it looked very
intriguing I don't see anything good no
more Audrey clauses in assault oh oh I
like her language sure out drug use some
sexual content disturbing behavior
oh well interesting I'll get one of you
200 bucks will you hunt me in the face
Oh
[Music]
graduation Elizabeth Olsen exam
la is the best I'm making a ton of new
friends a future hi I'm Taylor hey Rick
maybe horny little a stalker not anymore
[Music]
okay you need a realize it's just
described
willful about that right now this is my
better nature what is good on TV Thank
You where's my phone jealous favorite
print is the pitcher / sleeper so
they're just a joke you [ __ ] every
fellow little do is you right so just
care to box that would be doing like
this hey glider I was one of the comment
I'm not a psychopath I just want to be
her friend we've been dating a week
means are you letting you borrow a truck
and give him a [ __ ] damn bro you move
fast
[Music]
you watch it it was an accident
okay anything else I mean evil agency we
might have done all of your carpet and
we got in it
how'd you guys thank you for you soon oh
boy my god it's like this story of Wendy
Lee and pairing Nemiroff when they're
not at collider which one exactly be I
just a theory so nice yeah you know but
no that trailer did not go like based on
the title I did not think that's where
was going to go I literally in my head
Ingrid was what I was I was making
Western yeah kind of Western not like LA
eye cream oh my god that's so fun I mean
when I gathered from the first trailer
was Ingrid is a little bit how does that
funny huh all right I'll let you cry
whoo
no no we have you do a cannon so we got
a whole crew here you pan in on her
tears yeah right go I attend a campaign
yeah from the first trailer what I
gather from it was she's this girl who
tend to get obsessed with famous people
on social media now she has one where
she's actually getting close with that
person she yeah that's whether the
person has no idea I don't like that
elizabeth Olsen we knows doesn't know
that oh [ __ ] she's obsessed I love
stories of obsession it's rare where you
see a comedy don't you well I guess so I
mean they can be a little scary little
terminating but this is funny
yeah and I find that fascinating because
this could be easily be a horror movie
you know what I want to see somebody cut
the trailer take their like the poppy
you punch it out of my mouth and then we
cut into some heart like I don't know
some sort of like toy box cranking music
because the plot Adela Gary challenged
oh man although Jones challenged you
watching all audios I'm sure they'll get
this mess
Elizabeth Olsen letting loose having fun
in front of the camera being silly
yeah but she's been like a really
serious role that's no one likes Carla
which is kind of serious boy thought I
was over my game all syria's like
weeping crying rolls all the time and
this one she's like they lose have fun
yeah it's like the was she was she
wasn't okay Jo do you know what this
place is very different and I appreciate
that and I want to see this movie it
feels like a real dark comedy a lot of
time you seek dark comedies and then it
tends to just be really dark and not
that funny I feel like this will
actually have a great blend of being
actually dark and actually being funny
at the same time yeah and this is
something this is exactly something I
want to see Audrey Audrey Audrey Plaza
I think she's like made for roles like
this Oh totally she owns this she can go
she can hit that level of where that
character needs to go right I don't I
don't think many actresses can actually
get there because she's no she'd you
know she's crying in that one thing
she's like obsession I got out of that
yeah she's a Baldy actress yeah she does
like she's a daredevil of it all out
yeah I love that about yeah I do ages
job I do it yeah I like that she keeps
doing crazier roles now I did discover
her from Parks and Rec yeah she was
really subdued and super subtle and
super drug and to watch she does keep
that kind of humor and a lot of her
roles
I like seeing her break out into more
like emotional yeah and this is what
we're gonna get when she's like on
social media crying and yelling at
people like that looks real she looks
really upset how are ya yeah he goes
what's rubber thanks for tuning in to
this video today I'm Greg Alba subscribe
to the rejects click the notification
bell if you don't want to do that do
this when you leave on the movie couple
channel click that end card it's right
here if you've made it to this far
audience retention rate will tell me you
probably did not if you did click to
specific patreon.com slash for real
rejects if you made it this morning must
be a fan of the channel in some way
didn't debut I just think I got all the
Western